I'm speaking to you at what I know is an increasingly challenging time.
A time of disruption in the life of our country.
A disruption that has brought grief to some, financial difficulties to many...
...and enormous changes to the daily lives of us all.
I want to thank everyone on the NHS frontline, as well as care workers...
...and those carrying out essential roles...
...who selflessly continue their day-to-day duties outside the home...
...in support of us all.
I'm sure the nation will join me in assuring you that what you do is appreciated,...
...and every hour of your hard work brings us closer to a return to more normal times.
I also want to thank those of you who are staying at home,...
...thereby helping to protect the vulnerable,..
...and sparing many families the pain already felt by those who have lost loved ones.
Together we are tackling this disease,..
...and I want to reassure you that, if we remain united and resolute, then we will overcome it.
I hope, in the years to come, everyone will be able to take pride...
...in how they responded to this challenge.
And those who come after us will say the Britons of this generation were as strong as any.
That the attributes of self-discipline,...
...of quiet, good-humored resolve and of fellow feeling still characterize this country.
The pride in who we are is not a part of our past, it defines our present and our future.